avec un diplôme de cuisinier en poche
cédric jbeli n'était pas prédestiné à
l'animation en 2014
ils découvrent le métier d'animateur de
centre de loisirs un secteur qui lui a
plu tout de suite
j'aime bien l'ambiance bon allez avoir
le parcours des enfants les aider à
avancer je trouve ça bien de voir les
voir grandir on leur apporte quelque
chose et ça c'est très important
titularisé en octobre cédric jumelles y
travaille avec les maternelles ou les
élémentaires selon les besoins de la
structure
cet homme de 27 ans a grandi dans le
quartier des acacias à coignières j'ai
connu des personnes que des bêtises j'en
ai fait moi même
mais voilà on grandit on vous en faire
autre chose donc c'était l'opportunité
que la ville m'a donné de travailler que
les jeunes d'ici j'ai apprécié
aujourd'hui j'ai deux les jeunes
justement plus faire sur des bêtises
en grandissant on se rend compte que la
vie c'est pas forcément extorquer des
bêtises il est en bas du bâtiment
le directeur du centre qui le connaît
depuis l'enfance à penser directement à
lui pour intégrer son équipe
je le connais depuis de nombreuses
années c'est quelqu'un de sérieux c'est
quelqu'un qui aime rigoler il a toujours
eu un bon contact avec les les jeunes
delà de la ville donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas essayer avec vraiment les
enfants
de base âge qu'il a fait le bon choix au
début il a commencé il a fait des
remplacements cantine centre de loisirs
en vacation donc là il est passé tient
un agent titulaire cédric jbeli qui n'a
vécu quatre manières ne se voit pas
autre part toujours dans ma ville pour
les jeunes de ma vie c'est ce que j'aime
plus tard le coi n'y ait rien voudrait
travailler avec d'autres tranches d'âge
les adolescents ou voir les jeunes
adultes
toujours dans l'idée d'aider les jeunes